wenn wir uns mal wirklich realistisch
angucken das 100 konzerne für 71 prozent
der treibhausgasemissionen weltweit
verantwortlich sind ist es nicht mein
burger pas-team eine plastik zahnbürste
oder irgendwie meine reise nach italien
die für die klimakrise verantwortlich
ist sondern es sind diese 100 konzerne
die für 71 prozent der emissionen
verantwortlich sind herzlich willkommen
heute geht es um klima- oder anders
gesagt es geht um alles um unser aller
existenz 13 fragen hier kommt frage
nummer eins sind verbote eurer meinung
nach das letzte mittel diesen planeten
zu retten wenn ihr sagt er ja dann bitte
auf dem grünfeld positionieren wenn ihr
sagt nee da gibt es noch ganz andere
möglichkeiten dann bitte auf dem gelben
feld positionieren und bitte
[Musik]
so jetzt wissen wir buchstäblich wo ihr
steht aber wo steht ihr eigentlich
spätestens seit dem urteil des
bundesverfassungsgerichtes ende april
wissen wir ja wir müssen in sachen
klimaschutz schneller werden zumindest
schneller als bisher politisch geplant
damit die leute in 10 20 50 jahren nicht
viel härtere einschnitte erleben müssen
als leute heute also dass wir etwas
ändern müssen darüber herrscht einigkeit
die frage ist wie ändern wir etwas wie
geht's euch würde die er auf die grüne
seite gehen und sagen wir brauchen harte
einschnitte wir brauchen mehr verbote
oder würdet ihr sagen im gegenteil wie
die gelbe seite mehr
eigenverantwortlichkeit andere anreize
und 13 fragen jetzt geht's los mit
diskutieren grundsätzlich gilt wenn ihr
im laufe dieser folge der gegenseite in
einem punkt zustimmt dann dürft ihr
gerne auf sie zugehen das heißt einfach
einen schritt nach vorne gehen wenn ihr
sagt grundsätzlich finde ich ja deine
position gar nicht so blöd aber was du
jetzt gerade erzählt ist totaler
schwachsinn dann könnt ihr auch gerne
einen schritt zurückgehen
mein ziel am ende dieser folge ist es
möglichst viele von euch hier in der
mitte ist im sogenannten kompromiss feld
zu versammeln
denn diese sendung versucht ja vor allem
kompromisse und vielleicht sogar konsens
herzustellen und weniger nur ein bloßer
schlagabtausch zu sein also dass das
ziel dieser sendung mal sehen wie weit
wir kommen und wie weit ihr kommt ich
bin sehr gespannt wir legen jetzt los 13
fragen hier kommt also jetzt frage
nummer 2 und die stelle ich an kalla du
bist frei days for future aktivistin
warum glaubst du sind verbote der
richtige weg ich glaube wir müssen uns
zu allererst klar machen um was für
verbot es eigentlich geht das geht hier
nicht um das symbolische verbote von
einer plastiktüte oder die plastik
zahnbürste sondern es geht um die frage
zum beispiel insbesondere bereich
technologien was in technologien die wir
uns noch erlauben können in der
klimagerechten zukunft und da gibt es
eben sachen wie ein verbrenner motor
oder die verstromung von braunkohle
die wird es in der klimagerechten
zukunft wo wir ohne emissionen
wirtschaften wollen nicht mehr geben
können um die klimakrise zu bekämpfen
müssen wir jetzt effizient und schnell
emissionen senken
das werden wir nicht tun indem wir auf
den markt setzten oder nur an die
vernunft appellieren
sondern es braucht konkrete verbote
insbesondere auf unternehmensseite die
immer noch für die meisten emissionen
verantwortlich sind
wir haben es gesehen beim atomausstieg
da hat man es auch so gemacht das war
der richtige schritt
und genauso ist es bei der frage in der
klimakrise auch ist doch plausibel oder
geld ich frag mal richtung geldgeber
philippe gibt schon davon auf jeden fall
ich glaube dass es sehr plausibel ja in
meinem bereich sich die sache ein
bisschen anders im landwirtschaftlichen
bereich gibt es ganz viele leute die
wirklich was machen wollen die in den
klimawandel und die im moment durch
bestimmte regelungen die es jetzt gibt
total eingeschränkt sind und daher
glaube ich nicht dass wir dort mit
weiteren verbotenen die richtung
weiterkommen du denn nun unter anderem
beim automobilriesen arbeitet wird
wahrscheinlich sagen verbrenner
verbieten finde ich doof was würdest du
also sagen ja ich meine das beispiel was
du gebracht hast mit dem atomausstieg
ist ja ein sehr gutes das wird es jetzt
dass wir so weit sind dass wir nächstes
jahr das letzte atomkraftwerk vom netz
abschalten
aber dadurch dass du aus der atomkraft
aussteigt ist ja kein windkraft keine
windkraftanlage kein solarpanel gebaut
worden
ich meine wir müssen den fokus mehr auf
innovation legen wir sollten mehr über
das reden wo wir hinwollen welche
rahmenbedingungen wir setzen die die
infrastruktur von morgen aussieht wie
ist es zu einfach zu sagen wir fahren
nicht mehr mit verbrenner autos sondern
ich würde gerne über das andere reden
das ist die elektromobilität und wir
müssen jetzt darüber sprechen wie wir
dort schnell laden so ermöglichen dass
es sich für menschen anfühlt wie tanken
und dann glaube ich hast du eine
alternative dass die menschen ein
attraktives produkt kennen lernen dass
sie das schätzen und dass sie dann
merken ja das ist der bessere weg bier
glaubst du auch ja total statt es geht
ja nicht darum dass wir nur verbote
brauchen und dass alles andere nichts
nützt ich finde auch dass genau das was
du sagst anreize schaffen vor allem auch
unterstützend wirken sei es in der
wirtschaft sei es aber auch bei
privatpersonen ist total wichtig ich
glaube dass wir früher oder später
verbote brauchen weil es gerade nicht
darum geht irgendwie das klima oder die
umwelt retten sondern menschenleben zu
retten menschen davor zu retten zu
ertränken zu verhungern ihre
lebensgrundlage zu verlieren und am ende
auch ihr leben zu verlieren
okay das heißt da gibt es eine gewisse
kompromissbereitschaft aber die geht es
zu langsam
sie ist wegen sagst du im zweifel muss
halt das verbot habe ich erst verstanden
überzeugt ich das ja ich glaube wir
haben über verbote eine sehr
polarisierte debatte und das problem ist
sobald dann jemand sagt wir müssen was
verbieten kommen gleich sagt an zugleich
gegenwehr und man unterhält sich
überhaupt ich mir über das problem
eigentlich um die ursache des problems
vor allen dingen das problem hat
verboten ist wenn sie pauschal sind
verstehen menschen nicht was das mit
ihnen zu tun hat sie fühlt sich
ungerecht behandelt weil andere die
vielleicht verursachen das problem sind
es weniger durch die verbote betroffen
sind wir brauchen eine diskussion über
grenzen weil planetare grenzen grenzen
des wachstums und über grenzen der
individuellen handlungsmöglichkeiten ja
so wie du bist gleich nach vorne
gelaufen habe ich gesehen
ich stelle mir jetzt zu dass das wort
verbote für viele sehr provokant ist
menschen überfordern kann wenn man
alternativen zeigt was man anstelle
machen kann dann finde ich ist richtig
aber viele menschen haben wahrscheinlich
mit dem begriff verbot ein problem nicht
mit der umsetzung leider sind verbote
notwendig da wir sehen dass menschen
nicht freiwillig klimafreundlich handeln
deswegen müssen politisch verbote
maßnahmen oder regelung kommen damit
türen zum planeten retten können aber du
sagst du vollkommen zu recht das wort
verbot löst eine reaktors aus also
würdest du was vorschlagen wenn ich zum
beispiel verbiete das sonntags auto
gefahren wird oder an bestimmten
uhrzeiten auto gefahren wird dann greift
das nur ein symptom an nämlich viel auto
fahren das greift nicht an der ursache
an nämlich dass für infrastrukturen
haben in denen autos einfach bevorzugt
werden ja in denen öffentliche
verkehrsmittel nicht zur verfügung
stehen das heißt also wir müssen
eigentlich den ursachen ansetzen und ich
glaube da brauchen wir strengere ziele
wir brauchen ein bisschen hintere ziel
wir brauchen kurzfristiger ziele also
die 55 mit fünf jahres horizonten
arbeiten und nicht 25 jahre
wie geht es euch damit wenn ihr das wort
verbot hört denkt ihr dann geh mir weg
mit dem ding oder sagte er
wir haben halt keine zeit mehr dann muss
man vielleicht jetzt doch mal der harter
einschnitt kommen schreibt wieder gerne
in die kommentare
und jetzt die frage an euch hat euch das
was mir gerade erzählt hat überzeugten
teilen seid ihr nach vorne gegangen
ist es der richtige weg warum warum
gehen wir den da nicht also gerade der
punkt mit den kurzfristigeren zielen ist
finde ich einen sehr relevanten punkt
den du da gebracht hast denn was wir
bisher in der klimapolitik erleben sind
viele mehr oder weniger inhaltsleere
fernziele wenn wir über klimaneutralität
2050 sprechen was die bundesregierung
lage gemacht hat dann ist das kein ziel
was wirklich substanziell was zum
klimaschutz beiträgt wir brauchen jetzt
sozusagen kurzfristige planungshorizonte
auch gerade im bereich der wirtschaft
damit es da eben anreize gibt zu sagen
okay wenn wir wissen in fünf jahren gibt
es keine verbrenner motoren wer
beispielsweise gibt es ein anreiz
vielmehr dann in e technologie et cetera
zu investieren
dazu forschen und deswegen ist es ebenso
wichtig dass wir klimaziele für 2025 20
30 20 35 haben
denn genau das ermöglicht uns dann
sozusagen zugucken wie können wir das
als gesellschaft möglich machen
philipp ist sogar zurück gelaufen ich
bin gerade zurückgelaufen ja warum
ich glaube dass es vielmehr darum geht
eine kultur zu schaffen in der wir auch
solche langfristigen ziele wirklich bei
den menschen direkt verankern
wenn jetzt gesagt wird ja wir brauchen
ganz kurzfristige verbote das ist total
anfällig für populismus ja das kann die
nächste regierung wieder kippen oder die
nächste mode auch aber wenn wir eine
kultur verankern
in der es sage ich mal belohnt wird das
langfristige ziele wie zum beispiel
klimaneutralität verfolgt werden auch im
alltag ja dann ist es wirklich
nachhaltig bei allen märkten haye wenn
ich mich so verhalten dass die nächsten
generationen hier wirklich noch leben
können auf dem planeten dann bin ich
anerkannt dann bin ich in der mitte der
gesellschaft daher falsch wertschätzung
ja und wenn ich wertschätzung habe mich
wohl fühle dann brauche ich kein dickes
auto fahren also philips schlägt vor
einen kulturwandel wenn ich das richtig
sehe hat jasmin überzeugt ich das ja und
nein ich denke wenn man den menschen
genau sagt hey was ist das problem was
ist die ursache
was können wir machen dann können wir
glaube ich wirklich jeden auf dieser
erde für klimaschutz aktivieren aber ich
glaube dass diese kultur zu schaffen
braucht zeit viel zeit und das
die haben mir nicht deswegen ist es
jetzt gehst du wieder vor
hier widerspricht ihr selbst nein ich
finde das sehr was hier gesagt hat ist
dass es zeit braucht das ist das stimmt
ja und da da stimme ich zu auf jeden
fall das denke ich nach vorne aber sie
sagt auch die zeit haben wir nicht
ja das stimmt auch jetzt weiß nicht
genau wie vor drückt ja das ist ja aber
das kommt später geben also wo fange ich
mit mit verboten an oder wo können wir
sein lassen das ist eine schwierige
frage auf jeden aber genau diese grenze
versuchen wir jetzt gerade auszuloten
also das ist eine antwort ich glaube wir
brauchen so etwas wie berechenbarkeit
auf der einen seite dass die leute
wissen welches ziel wir wann erreichen
und wie auch dass wir so was brauchen
die akzeptanz und deswegen sollten wir
sehr sehr aus meiner sicht sehr sorgsam
damit umgehen und uns gut überlegen wie
wir diese transformation gestalten weil
es ist mehr als nur klimaschutz
es geht auch um die frage von
persönlichen freiheiten das hat das
bundesverfassungsgericht geurteilt dass
klimaschutz und freiheit das steht nicht
mehr irgendwie so sondern das ist 1 auf
der anderen seite geht es um die frage
von wohlstand das geht darum dass
menschen ihren arbeitsplatz behalten
vielleicht geht es auch darum dass wir
neue arbeitsplätze schaffen ja du hast
recht gebrauchen kann
diese kurzfristigen ziele im fünf jahres
rhythmus dass man sie überprüfen kann
wir dürfen aber auch nicht davon
ausgehen dass wir die technologie die
wir 20 30 oder 40 oder 50 haben dass das
das ist was wir heute haben wir werden
sprünge haben also werden wir besser
werden jeder kann sich noch an den
moment im jahr 2005 erinnern als ein
nokia handy in der hand hatte und drei
jahre später hatte ein iphone gehabt und
keiner wusste damals was ein smartphone
ist so wird es bei der
batterietechnologie sein
so wird es aber bestimmt auch was
stromnetze betrifft und so wird es auch
was den ausbau der erneuerbaren energien
und die effizienz betrifft seien
carla hast du damit aber nicht überzeugt
warum nicht also wenn ich mir angucke wo
wir in deutschland gerade stehen dann
haben wir in co2 budget also die menge
an co2 die deutschland noch ausstoßen
darf um einen gerechten beitrag zur
einhaltung des 1,5 grad zu leisten
das kann man ja von den weltweiten co2
budget herunterbrechen auf deutschland
wenn wir uns das angucken wo wir gerade
sind dann haben wir nicht mal mehr
sieben jahre also nicht mal sieben
jahren ist es aufgebraucht wenn wir
soweit der mädchen wie bis jetzt
und da möchte ich mich als person die
leute kennt die schon jetzt von den
folgen der
thema krise betroffen sind als auch die
weiß dass ich in der zukunft 20 50 20 60
das vermutlich noch erleben werde mich
nicht verlassen möchten auf irgend eine
technologie die vielleicht kommt aber
vielleicht auch nicht und auf irgend
eine effizienzsteigerung die vielleicht
kommt oder vielleicht auch nicht ich
sage nicht dass man deswegen sagt wir
brauchen keine ziele aber ich glaube wir
brauchen etwas optimismus und wir müssen
uns gedanken machen wie wir dann stück
für stück diese ziele eben nachschärfen
können um sie auch verlässlich zu halten
ich glaube aber dass man weil du gesagt
hast wir müssen sehr sehr schnell
handeln 1,5 grad wenn man das 1,5 grad
ziel komplett auf die usa anwenden würde
dann müsste man in drei jahren dort
komplett auf null sein
ich glaube das schafft man nicht so
melanie ist die ganze zeit hin und
hergelaufen sowohl bei kahla als auch
bei dir also wo stehst du gerade dass
die politik vor allen dingen auf
technologien setzt hat oft auch damit zu
tun dass da so ein optimismus herrscht
und hat das gefühl technologie kann wo
alle probleme lösen ja aber es ist schön
einfach ja so weil die technologie da
ist sind alle probleme weg das ist aber
meistens nicht so viele technologien
haben auch ein ziemlich harten schwanz
der kulturwandel ist vielleicht etwas
was langfristiger wirkt den handwerker
eigentlich schon also wir haben schon
seit vielen jahren eigentlich hohe
zustimmung zu klimaschutzzielen habe
haben mir sehr umweltbewusste
bevölkerung das heißt nicht dass jeder
umwirft handelt aber sozusagen bewusst
dann ist das schon angekommen
das problem ist aber dass häufig ein
widerspruch erlebt wird also man hält
sich selbst vielleicht ein etwas habe
das gefühl die anderen machen ja gar
nicht mit dann hat man das gefühl ich
kann ja optics verändern ich habe nicht
genug selbstwirksamkeit oder ich selber
versuche fleisch zu verzichten
aber gleichzeitig das vielleicht nur
ultra billig das kostet drei euro das
kilo ist sogar billiger als gemüse dass
man das gefühl hat das mach ich denn
eigentlich
deswegen zieht man sich zurück und macht
dann halt das was man immer macht man
fliegt oder seine gewohnheiten dann sagt
zum beispiel da brauchen wir halt harte
einschnitte nicht zum beispiel auch mal
ein klares verbot also ich möchte
persönlich die wahl haben oder die
freiheit haben insofern dinge zu
konsumieren die halt tatsächlich anderen
menschen ihre freiheit auf ein gesundes
leben nehmen also es ist jetzt sehr
utopisch gedacht aber glaubst du dich
stand dass sowas hier ein fleisch verbot
symbolisieren würde was zum beispiel der
fleischerzeugung alles mit einher geht
also ob nicht auch da dann vielleicht
als aufklärungsmaßnahmen irgendwie
sowieso wird jetzt fleisch verboten das
muss ja schon jetzt krass schädlich sein
für mich für die umwelt für die tiere
denn was auch immer ob das nicht auch in
dem moment ganz schön was du gesagt
dass man so eine kultur schafft dass
leute schon verstehen worum es
eigentlich geht das damit vielleicht
auch erzeugt würde und wenn es für alle
verboten würde wäre es ja auch nicht
ungerecht weil dann alle gleichermaßen
davon betroffen neben aber wenn du das
fleisch in deutschland verbietet dann
haben wir doch damit global kein problem
das ist der punkt ja wast aber in
deutschland machen könntest ist und das
passiert ich finde es könnte noch mehr
passieren dass wir alternativen schaffen
ich finde wenn du heute im supermarkt
ist und sie ist wie viel wie viel
alternativen ist zum fleisch gibt also
vegane und vegetarische alternativen
dann ist etwas ganz anderes als das was
vor 55 jahren erlebt haben und wenn wir
dort mehr rein stecken würden wenn diese
ganzen fuß start ups nicht immer nur
amerikanische werden sondern vielleicht
auch mal europäische oder deutsche
ich finde diese waffe und das spielt
auch so ein bisschen in diese frage des
kulturwandels rhein ist eine pseudo
debatte und auch gefährlich denn genau
die hat uns an diesen punkt gebracht
dass die klimakrise so und die maßnahmen
zur bekämpfung der klimakrise so
unglaublich polarisiert behandelt werden
gesellschaftlich weil wir so viel über
individuelle entscheidungen sprechen die
aber wenn wir uns mal wirklich
realistisch angucken das 100 konzerne
für 71 prozent treibhausgasemissionen
weltweit verantwortlich sind ist es
nicht mein burger pas-team eine plastik
zahnbürste oder irgendwie meine reise
nach italien die für die klimakrise
verantwortlich ist sondern es sind diese
100 konzerne die für 71 prozent der
emissionen verantwortlich sind inmitten
der klimakrise mehr als 20 21 können
nicht banken neue pipelines finanzieren
konzerne neue gaskraftwerke bauen denn
es ist ganz klar dass es nicht die
zukunft das sind nicht technologien die
wir brauchen und das schafft ja
unglaubliche fahrt abhängigkeiten wenn
wir jetzt eine pipeline bauen dann wird
dadurch für die nächsten jahrzehnte
erdöl gefördert was unser co2 budget
einfach sprengt deswegen ist ganz klar
sowas darf nicht mehr passiert und das
hat euch auf philipp durch hat es
offenbar überzeugt das argument auf
jeden fall jetzt kamen wieder
fleischkonsum verbieten ja ich habe da
auch eine andere sichtweise zu wir haben
landwirtschaft systeme wenn wir jetzt
die viecher auf die weide stellen da
haben wir auf einmal eigentlich keine
methan emissionen mehr wenn wir wald
weide und eine rotation zweite
kombinieren dann überkompensieren
wiederkäuer ihre klimaschädlichen
treibhausgasemissionen
das heißt weidevieh haltung mit einem
richtigen management wäre also
potenziell eine kohlenstoffsenke oder
eine treibhausgas senke so
aber in der öffentlichkeit heißt es ja
fleisch verbieten das andere ist zum
beispiel wenn nicht mehr angucke man
sagt deutschland verbraucht für
videostreaming so viel energie wie die
ganze volkswirtschaft schon von spanien
also da will ich doch vielleicht
videostreaming einfach mal verbieten
youtube verbieten so ja und dann werde
ich glaube du bist youtube das ist das
ist der punkt es ist wahnsinnig komplex
und das ist auch das was du sagst als
individuum ist man da total verloren und
verbote sind oft auch kontraproduktiv
also ich würde schon zuständig auch
sagen dass wirklich erhalten also sagen
dass man sicherheit verbote die nicht
gut genug durchdacht sind dann halt
genau das gegenteil bewirken das ultra
gefährlich deswegen braucht es ja auch
richtig viele menschen richtig viel
ahnung und wirklich zu gucken welche
verbote machen denn tatsächlich sind und
müssen sich halt auf fragen das kann
nicht einfach über die menschen dieser
meisten betrifft hinweg entschieden
werden
es gibt ja auch formate wie zum beispiel
die bürger räte wo eben alle möglichen
leute gefragt werden wo ein informierter
prozess stattfindet ja mit allen
möglichen fachleuten in der beteiligung
so dass wir gute lösungen erarbeiten
können sie aber gemeinsam arbeiten sie
dann aber auch von allen getragen werden
und das denke ich es wirklich nachhaltig
das ist wiederum im plädoyer für eine
demokratisierung der demokratie wenn ich
das richtig verstehe also auf jeden fall
ja ja ja ja vor allen dingen eine also
ein mehr im power mensch und meer bottom
up prozessen also das was wir eigentlich
brauchen ist dass wir nicht zu sagen
elitär in elitären kreisen über verbote
oder wünscht es um unerwünschtes handel
sprechen sondern eben viel mehr
demokratische prozesse haben in solche
aushandlungen regional und lokal
stattfinden also wir sind da auf einem
unglaublich hohen ross und glauben wir
haben uns wahnsinnig entwickelt und er
reduzieren schon unsere mission aber ein
großteil geben wir einfach ab da diese
schöne neue technikwelt bei uns heißt
letztendlich in china fallen die
emissionen an da werden die solarzellen
produziert und dann vielleicht auch noch
die elektroautos und das zweite was
damit dranhängt ist einfach eine
unglaubliche ungerechtigkeit und das
haben wir hier bei uns im land auch wenn
es um arbeitsplätze geht ja dann habe
ich ein problem wenn wir sagen ja wir
verbieten jetzt den kohleabbau und dann
sind die leute arbeitslos aber wir
müssen uns einfach eine andere frage
stellen die frage ist ist arbeit
überhaupt das an das existenzsicherung
gekoppelt sein
kann also klimaschutz geht eigentlich
nur mit einem völlig anderen
gesellschaftsmodell also ich denke was
total wichtig ist darüber zu unterhalten
gesellschaftlich aushandlungsprozess
dazu zu haben das eigentlich
lebensqualität ist und diese vorstellung
von lebensqualität verändert sich ja
sehr starker und gerade ist unsere sind
von vielen menschen die vorstellung von
lebensqualität gekoppelt an konsum der
aber im endeffekt eigentlich was ist was
du kurzzeitig zufrieden stellt ja so die
lebensqualität forschung zeit eigentlich
am wichtigsten ist für menschen dass sie
soziale interaktionen haben dass die
selbstwirksamkeit erfahren das gefühl
haben sie können ihr leben bestimmen und
dass sie ihren vorstellungen nach auch
ihre zukunft entwickeln kann also die
zukunftsaussicht und das gerade wird
einem mit dem klimawandel genommen wie
geht er jetzt mit menschen um
ich frage mal an grün die sich das jetzt
anhören und sagen okay dafür das wort
fleisch verbot da fiel das wort
verbrenner verbot wahrscheinlich wird
mein strom teurer und ich habe angst um
meinen job und jetzt erklärt ihr mir wir
sollen jetzt noch mehr harte einschnitte
haben was antwortet ihr solchen zu
scheuen
ich glaube wir müssen einmal noch
sozusagen wirklich bei der realität
anfangen was es eigentlich die folge der
klima also was sind die folgen der
klimakrise die uns hier erwarten die es
schon gibt es auch hier schon gibt also
wenn wir uns auch die sommer angucken du
kannst es sicherlich irgendwie am besten
bestätigen haben gerade landwirtinnen
und landwirte sehen schon heute die
folgen der klimakrise durch die größten
dürren in europa seit jahrhunderten also
das glaube ich noch mal klar zu machen
was bedeutet das eigentlich ist das eine
und dann ist die zweite frage glaube ich
eine ganz essenzielle diskurs frage wir
müssen darüber sprechen was passiert mit
leuten deren arbeitsplätze tatsächlich
bedroht sind durch klimaschutzmaßnahmen
wie können wir dafür sorgen dass
regionen in denen strukturwandel
stattfinden muss mitgenommen werden dass
wir perspektiven schaffen aber nicht die
aufgabe die wir haben die so essenziell
ist denn wir uns auch völkerrechtlich
verpflichtet haben mit dem der unter der
unterschrift des pariser klimaabkommens
die nicht einfach zu verneinen und ich
glaube darüber den diskurs zu führen
anstatt generell abstand zu halten von
dem ziel weil man sollte nur das wollen
wir jetzt nicht das wäre total wichtig
um den diskurs dann so zu führen dass
wir als gesellschaft darüber diskutieren
können
wie gewonnen wie wollen wir denn alle
mitnehmen da würde ich genau da ein
haben wird wenn wir dann an
demokratischen prozessen und sagen was
wollen wir denn
dann was von was müssen wir vielleicht
verbieten dann haben wir unglaublich
viele hebel in der hand und dann können
wir sagen wir können uns um den
kulturwandel kümmern
und jetzt können wir ganz ganz konkret
das und das machen und das ist etwas wo
ich einfach persönlich sagen muss in der
landwirtschaft hätten wir da ein riesen
hebel
wenn das geld da wäre und der
gesellschaftliche das gesellschaftliche
interesse da was zu machen und da können
wir sagen ja wir können durch bäume
durch wieder begrünung der welt ganz
ganz viel abfangen
wir können uns zeit verschaffen das ist
sozusagen das was die un die djs zu
höchstens nennen ja mit natur basierten
methoden arbeiten da haben wir einen
riesen potenzial um eben ganz
kurzfristig zu sagen wir hauen dann
stoppt rhein bei der klimaerwärmung wir
haben jetzt über verschiedene ich sag
mal die war nicht ganz ernst gemeinte
verbots vorschläge gesprochen es gibt
wird in den nächsten zukunft hier kein
fleisch verbot in deutschland geben hast
du denn überhaupt den eindruck dass man
mit harten einschnitten in deutschland
zum beispiel weltweit was lösen kann ich
meine wir leben in deutschland und wir
haben erstmal verantwortung für uns und
für unser land und damit die mir schon
als vorbild wenn mir das schon erreichen
dh es ist es wird mitwirken es löst
natürlich nicht das komplette problem
aber wir dienen als vorbilder und sind
vielleicht ein best-practice-beispiel
und andere können sich dadurch ein
vorbild nehmen und das gleiche machen da
sagt natürlich vielleicht der ein oder
andere ja warum soll ich denn jetzt hier
noch auf vielleicht irgendwie noch noch
ökologischer denken als sowieso schon
vielleicht sogar noch weniger fleisch
essen während die amis da drüben mit
ihren dicken karren durch die gegend
fahren also ganz ehrlich da hab ich
keine lust drauf sozial und fair naja du
musst man kann die diskussion ja anders
führen deswegen bin ich auch ein schritt
nach vorn gegangen weil so du hast ja
gesagt wir können ein beispiel dafür
sein dass sich andere an uns orientieren
können und das ist ja unsere aufgabe
also zwei prozent co2 ausstoß dafür sind
wir in deutschland verantwortlich
weltweit für ein prozent der
weltbevölkerung viertgrößte
volkswirtschaft und wenn wir zeigen dass
wir das machen können im laufenden
betriebs und land zu erneuern und das
co2 freie produkte ja nicht unbedingt
schlechtere sein müssen das können auch
bessere sein beim auto werden bessere
sein dann werden sich andere an uns
orientieren wir reden ja jetzt ihr wären
hier tatsächlich über wahrscheinlich
auch einschnitte in einer gesellschaft
können wir nicht drum herum reden aber
auch wenn du sagst wohlstand würdest du
gerne erhalten
aber so ein will
wir erhalten nicht müssten wir erhalten
wir müssen uns aber fragen der wohlstand
definieren also weil die habe wohlstand
schon mal wird ja ganz ganz viel immer
noch gemessen als bruttoinlandsprodukt
und wenn wir uns mal angucken was das
bruttoinlandsprodukt oder generell viele
volkswirtschaftliche indikatoren die so
funktionieren bilden ja überhaupt gar
nicht tatsächlichen gesellschaftlichen
wohlstand ab der dax steigt während der
korona krise auf neue höchstwerte
gleichzeitig haben ruhe sind
hunderttausende leute in kurzarbeit
kinder können nicht zur schule gehen
leute können ihren jobs nicht ausüben
und können nur zu hause sitzen haben
keine sozialkontakte
das heißt wir müssen doch auch
anerkennen dass wohlstand viel viel mehr
als so einen zahlen indikator aus der
wirtschaft ist und ich glaube das ist
ein ganz ganz essenzielle punkt wenn wir
davon sprechen wir wollen wohlstand
erhalten dann müssen uns erst mal fragen
was ist wohlstand überhaupt deswegen
gibt es länder wie beispielsweise
neuseeland jetzt sowas eingeführt haben
wie involving index also ein wohlstands
index der genau so was wie
kindererziehung
ja und auch gesellschaftliche
ungleichheit mit einbeziehen der
bildungschancen mit einbezieht um eben
zu sagen wir haben ein indikator der
wohlstand anders einordnet als nur
anhand von irgendeiner
volkswirtschaftlichen zahl die steigen
kann während es den leuten viel
schlechter geht ich glaube wenn wir
jetzt was wenn wir etwas erreichen
wollen dann müssen wir in zahn zulegen
und wenn man gesehen hat wie schnell wir
in der lage sind einen impfstoff zu
entwickeln
dann zeigt das doch was für eine power
in den leuten steckt wenn der rahmen
klar definiert ist dann machen sich die
leute auf dem weg und sagen ich kann
damit geld verdienen ich kann damit
meine arbeitsplätze sichern und ich kann
auch ein gutes leben führen und von mir
aus sollen ja auch ein großes haus
danach bauen ist alles gut also wenn du
redest die ganze zeit davon wohlstand
muss erhalten bleiben wir müssen beide
fortschritt aber mal angenommen dass
wirklich weniger von allem wirklich
effektiv wäre erst dann bereit auf was
abzugeben würdest du nicht auch menschen
sagen er dann verzichtet man auf das und
mal auf das immer noch das leben
trotzdem noch genug zu essen ein dach
überm kopf genug zu trinken leben in der
sicheren welt der fall erst ich total
richtig seinen eigenen konsum und sein
eigenes verhalten ständig zu
hinterfragen und zu überlegen muss
dieses t shirt sein muss diese jeans
seien brauche ich das zehnte paar
sneaker oder brauche ich nicht aber es
ist eine individuelle entscheidung die
will ich nicht für irgendjemanden
abnehmen ich will dir nicht sagen
das würde ja also das würde ja bedeuten
können wenn jetzt nicht auf
individueller ebene sondern halt
wirtschaftlich politisch was entschieden
wird das dann für dich am ende heißen
können kannst dann nicht mehr jeden tag
autos von fleisch essen
streaming der angucken das ist ja was
was jetzt nicht was karl auch gesagt hat
es geht nicht darum was du darfst oder
nicht sondern was am ende bei rumkommt
werden wir halt krasse maßnahmen die wir
dringend brauchen jetzt politisch
entscheiden lassen dass wir dann
vielleicht am ende weniger von unserem
wohlstand behalten können wäre der
ausgleich
wir haben wir haben ja ein system was
einen ganz klaren rahmen in richtung co2
neutralität gesteckt hat das heißt jeder
mensch der irgendein produkt anbietet
wird sich jetzt die frage stellen wie
geht s auch co2 neutral
und wenn du dir denn wenn du dir den co2
preis und seine entwicklung anguckt dann
werden diejenigen die das nicht schaffen
nicht mehr existieren können ich glaube
wir sind einigermaßen klar geworden wer
wo steht ich glaube die trennlinien sind
auch deutlich geworden
darum geht es ja bei dieser sendung auch
dass wir überhaupt wissen also was
vereint uns und was trennt uns ich würde
gerne mal zum abschluss kommen zu einer
sogenannten kompromiss runde
ich würde einen vorschlag machen in der
hoffnung dass ihr da alle zustimmt und
einen schritt nach vorne gehen könnt ihr
könnt auch sagen was ist das für ein
komischer vorschlag bleibe ich lieber
stehen und danach seid ihr in euren
gruppen aufgefordert einen vorschlag zu
formulieren der die andere seite zu euch
holt ich glaube ich würde vielleicht
alle einen schritt vorgehen wenn ich
sage die weiterverteilung von schlechtem
gewissen an endverbraucher innen also
chemie als überbegriff hilft uns
dauerhaft nicht weiter wir müssen in
jedem fall politisch vorgehen und nicht
so sehr an einzelne konsument innen
antreten sind wir uns da einig große
schritte nach vorn
so jetzt seid ihr dran ihr dürft jetzt
mal kurz die köpfe zusammenstecken
corona konnten innerhalb eurer gruppen
und überlegen kurzer zeit gebe ich euch
ob es eine formulierung gibt einsatz
gibt wo er glaubt die anderen kommen auf
uns zu
also braucht
ich mache dir das mit der planeten
rettung im alltag sc noch fleisch ist er
weniger fleisch isst ja gar kein fleisch
mehr habt ihr ein schlechtes gewissen
wenn ihr zu lange netflix schaut
stichwort strom verbraucht oder sagt dir
lass mich in ruhe damit ich habe ein
wunderbar reines gewissen schreibt sie
mir gerne in die kommentare
die menschen irgendwie gerade wunderbar
wir stehen alle wieder beisammen wie
sieht's aus gruppe gelb habt ihr
irgendwas was ihr den anderen sagen
würdet wo die vielleicht sogar noch
einen schritt näher zu euch kommt eine
gute mischung haben wir ja also wir sind
dafür verpflichtungen einzuführen
zwar ein sozial ökologische
bilanzierungen für unternehmen
organisationen institutionen und diese
zeit ökologische transformation
voranzubringen
also nicht ein verbot sondern eine
verpflichtung zur bilanzierung in
sozialen ökologischen sinne wir wollen
mehr transparenz haben etwas was die
nachvollziehbarkeit eben der
transformation betrifft also auch die
frage nicht nur die ist ein produkt
sondern wo kommt es her bekommen seine
bestandteile her unter welchen
bedingungen ich will jetzt erst mal
wissen ob die drei da drüben wir
zusammen mit gehen und sagen jack swing
kids oder ob er sagt das ist ja aber
natürlich nicht ist ja auch klar dass
einige nicht als einzigen ansatz aber
100 leuten aber eine möglichkeit die auf
jeden fall was bringen würde
habt ihr auch ein vorschlag eine
formulierung ja wir haben ein bisschen
allgemeiner formuliert mal angenommen
nach ausreichender wissenschaftlicher
beratung und allen mit einbezogen die
davon betroffen sind würde irgendwann
langfristig ein verbot in kraft treten
was aber zu 100 prozent dafür sorgt dass
wirklich weniger menschen unter der
klimakrise leiden werden dann wärt ihr
bereit das verbot auch so zu
unterzeichnen fragezeichen da habt ihr
irgendwas im kopf hatten beispiel ist
muss jetzt nicht genau das seien aber
zum beispiel so was wie der
kohleausstieg ist eigentlich schon
beispiel dafür dass ausstieg dann
langfristig wir haben ja auch wir haben
darüber gesprochen es gibt so viele
verbote die niemand irgendwie kritisch
findet oder vorgaben am ende jeder von
uns schnell sich im auto wenn er auto
fährt sicherlich an was auch mal leute
irgendwie den totalen aufreger fanden
und genau das selbe halt auch könnt ihr
mit ja kann ich das ja die damit wenn
damit der co2 wenn damit der
kohleausstieg gemeint ist
dann würde ich unterschreiben aber nur
dann wenn es vor 20 38 passiert ja gut
klappt damit seit der attacke wunderbar
ganz herzlichen dank es hat großen spaß
gemacht wie immer in dieser diskussion
wird es nicht so sein dass am ende alle
mit einer tollen lösung für die planeten
rettung nach hause gehen aber vielleicht
mit ein bisschen mehr verständnis und
auch die frage was heißt eigentlich
verbot deswegen finde ich euren letzten
kompromissvorschlag auch gar nicht so
schlecht mal drüber nachzudenken das
verbot nicht per se negativ sein muss
schließlich ist es uns auch verboten bei
rot über die ampel zu gehen zum beispiel
das haben ja auch irgendwie akzeptiert
vielen vielen dank
das waren 13 fragen ja wir haben über
verbote in dem sinn ja gesprochen dass
es um richtungsentscheidungen für
bestimmte lösungen geht und ich glaube
dass wir diesen streit denen wir auch
geführt haben dass wir den intensiver
führen müssen dass wir den auch als
gesellschaft intensiver führen müssen
weil nur dadurch können lösungen
entstehen
ich glaube gerade dieses
gesamtgesellschaftliche bewusstsein für
klimagerechtigkeit dass das gestiegen
ist in den letzten jahren ist etwas was
mir hoffnung gibt die leeren
versprechungen die uns teilweise
unternehmen mit wiimotion kampagnen und
politiker in ihrem wahlprogramm machen
das ist nicht das was mir mut gibt wenn
ich auf dieses bundestagswahl ja schauen
sondern es sind die menschen die ich
tagtäglich bei freilich user aber auch
woanders erlebe die mir hoffnung geben
denn ich sehe immer wieder und wieder
und letzten jahre haben sie auch
bewiesen die veränderung kommt aus der
mitte der gesellschaft
bei diesem thema ist glaube ich ganz
deutlich geworden im grunde herrscht ja
einigkeit dass wir was tun müssen aber
es kommt dann eben doch auf die details
an denn am ende musst du halt ein gesetz
schreiben und da musst du dir klar sein
was steht da wirklich drin und ich
glaube da hat die diskussion heute
bestimmt geholfen den einen oder anderen
besser zu verstehen
wenn euch diese folge gefallen hat dann
abonniere doch unseren kanal nämlich
hier eine weitere folge 13 fragen gibt
es da oben und ein weiteres video zum
thema findet ihr hier